but my Chaplin has been detained at a
funeral and therefore with your
hopefully all authority and approval I'm
going to read a prayer on her behalf
Lord you have entrusted us as stewards
of your creation please guide our hearts
as we make our decisions we seek you
first in all we do together we give you
our business our customers and our
workforce
may we be always been mindful of their
service we confess we confess that we
are nothing without you and I trust in
you is in you completely Armand thank
you please
right
just one or two housekeeping rolls
firstly for those of you who are
speaking who are unfamiliar with our
ways could I request that you speak into
the microphone but not absolutely next
to it just a short distance away
otherwise it won't be picked up for the
recording and before you start to speak
can you press the central button at the
bottom of the microphone box so that the
two lights red lights are showing if you
could then switch the microphone off at
the end that'd be very helpful I'd also
just remind everybody that if there is
was to be a far the Forex that's a
marked in this room and clearly if you
if we need to go we gotta go right I'll
now ask the I call on the executive
director to report the list of apologies
[Applause]
councillor Gittings councillor kendall
and councillor right Thank You members
officers can I ask you to make any
declarations of interest on any items of
business that we are considering today
yes chair I would like to make a
collective declaration a personal
interest for all officers employed of
the council in relation to IT item 14
thank you as well are there any other
declarations of interest
if not we'll move on to the third point
which is the minutes these have been
circulated the minutes of the meeting of
the 17th of December you've all had a
copy of them
if anybody has any concerns if not
please can I have a proposal for those
minutes thank you assignment cancel
Orton is proposing them cancel Barnes
our second them are we agreed on those
thank you a blind knight to move on to
my notes it counts a lot and thank you
for proposing I'm reminded that you
weren't actually present at the meeting
so whilst you may have watched on video
I believe we should have a seconder
thank you very much right so we have now
approved the minutes if we move on
therefore two announcements firstly I
would like to congratulate Beverly
Cooper achieved 40 years service with
the council
[Applause]
I'm sorry she's not here but we all
understand that's how some people like
to take these awards so moving on to
engagements and presentation firstly I
would like to welcome our new head of
paid service as well and to look forward
to a long and illustrious career with
strapped for District Council and I'm
sure all my colleagues share that view
with me I'd also like to welcome council
Williams back council Williams
delightful to see you back and I'm very
pleased to say that rock okay what's the
Chairman been up to and if we move on
Lord Lieutenant and high sheriff's carol
service was just after our last meeting
attended by myself and the vice chairman
we then moved on beginning of this year
over the page I don't know if mr. perks
is president he features quite a lot of
these slides we he organized this
strategist council Sports Awards hosted
by Steve Perry a GB swimmer Olympic
medalist
there are a number of different
categories on the next slide please
you can read that you're doing better
than I am but I'd like to congratulate
all the winners for those Awards it was
the majority were youths and younger
people are here is mr. perks it was a
very successful evening and is wonderful
to see not only the smile on the winners
faces but the significant number of
nominations that we had for all the
categories all coming from Stratford
Stratford district all covering a huge
range of different activities from
Biddeford to ships turned to Southam and
really great to see so congratulations
Tony for organizing that evening and it
was
great so moving on to the next one I was
then invited to go and see a strap for
Girls Grammar School production of into
the woods and it always great to see our
schools in this district and in
particular in this town producing what
the quality of performance that I saw
that night it did follow on from just
after the academic results being
published for last summer and it is
hugely rewarding to see that our two
better known schools the Gretna Girls
Grammar School and King Edward's school
were vying for the top two places in
warwickshire between them and I think
one one under one category and if you
recount it on a different score the
other one one and I think it is it is
terrific that we are surrounded on each
side by two such excellent academic
institutions moving on we there I then
tempt the Lord Mayor of Coventry civic
service I think for those who remember
what rain was it was one of the few days
when it did rain and we marched happily
in the rain for a while and then moving
on we then have a civic dinner in the
Magnificent chambers of the the Lord
Mayor which says you've been German
before we'll have visited I think that
dates back to the mid 13 hundreds up
building and some of the original glass
work is still in the windows it's a
terrific terrific example or something
to survive Coventry if we could move on
we then had the Stratford Pride Awards
and once again 15 different categories
where there were many names put forward
for each category I was invited to be
one of the judges it was incredibly
difficult task because there was so many
excellent examples of really good
service in this district to the district
we presented the long term volunteer
but every single Award winner and all
the Nanni's deserved to be there tonight
all that that evening I just like to add
there were two additional awards one
which were related specifically to this
council and that there was a special
recognition of councillor Eric Payne's
contribution over his lengthy period
both as an austere as well as a district
councillor to for the benefit of the
whole district so that was great to see
the one board that we did have which we
were connected with and I did stand away
from this election or vote for this one
the Victorian Christmas market that our
team here have a lot to work to work
with won an award that night so again
well done to Tony and his team and I
think we have the award and thanks bring
it up so for those who haven't seen it
prior to Stratford district awards Turin
tourism initiative of the year for the
Victorian Christmas market I hope many
of you attended a month ago and if you
didn't there will be an opportunity next
year and please make sure you do better
next time but it was a really great
occasion and there were some wonderful
stanza moving on one please
now this is again it was terrific to see
this was the third anniversary of the
Stratford on Avon Park run organised
again by mr. perks or we use his
facilities and I'm afraid to say that he
did manage to persuade the Chairman's to
take part which says you see my email
was something I was delighted to take
part so I realized a detriment running
five kilometres but it was great to see
a team from Stratford I wasn't I didn't
lead from the front I didn't follow up
entirely from behind but I'm glad to say
Tony did lead from the front whose first
Park run anew and he came in first at
the Stratford team so well done
on that one and then there were a number
of very competent runners it was great
to see so many people are in our own
Park and if you just move on one side
please and there is the team in our
Stratford district council t-shirts
so um well I'll turn you on that line
and on and then yesterday I attended the
works of district councils chairman
service at All Saints Church in M Scott
and that concludes my engagements over
the last so it's a lot previous meeting
so we now move on and I would like to
invite the leader of the council Thank
You chair I'll be brief
I also attended the Sports Awards and
the pride of Stratford Awards I attended
an Aston Martin Lagonda stakeholder
briefing which was extremely interesting
as part of the West Midlands combined
Authority I've been appointed to an
economic contingency board which will be
a short board looking at the potential
impacts of an Odile brexit we've had two
meetings up to now and I daresay there
will be a third in due course although
of course when we exit Brett's et's
sorry when we have bread's it appears to
be a very moveable feast and finally
I've made some slight changes to the
lady's statement and I will get those
circulated with the minutes of this
meeting thank you
I'd move on to our head of paid service
for her update flu so their announcement
Thank You chairman and so I'd like to
make an announcement relating to the PA
challenge so this is the Local
Government Association undertook a
corporate PA challenge in March 2017 and
they will be coming back to undertake a
review on Thursday and Friday of this
week
now the PA challenge is
an excellent opportunity for the council
to receive constructive challenge around
five core questions which form the key
components looked at by all corporate
peer challenges the purpose of the
review is to measure the council's
response to the previous page challenge
and the findings as well as identify new
opportunities for continuous improvement
the peer challenge group will be led by
Antoinette Jackson chief exec for
Cambridge City Council councillor Peter
Fleming for the leader from Seven Oaks
and will be supported by Joe Wagstaff
from Watford and Three Rivers Council
and also James Millington who is the LGA
peer challenge manager this group are
significantly experienced in areas
critical to the the performance and
improvement of the council and I know
that some of you will be involved in
this peer challenge and we look forward
to walking and them to Stratford thank
you thank you very much I know move on
to public participation questions the
public there has been one written
question received from David Curtis on
behalf the Friends of those residents
would you like to come forward mr.
Curtis are you here
now this class it's the questions you've
asked your question of but it had a copy
of it and you've had a response form
counselor organ who's the portfolio's
member responsible for that area do you
have a supplementary question what
relating to her response in which case
can we have your supplementary questions
thank you there was no consultation with
the residents or ward councillor as
defined by counsel on counsels own
website a press release is not
consultation inaccurate information was
given to planning committee by
councillors and officers the council's
own consultants options report fails to
raise widely known issues a parking
antisocial behavior road safety and
conservation and is clearly not
impartial had counsel consulted
residents these issues would have been
readily identified counselors at
Planning Committee chose to ignore
highways advice about road safety see if
anyone gets hurt can you go to the
question please yes but this is relevant
with respect the council breached
Freedom of Information legislation on at
least two occasions by overrunning the
time limit and now refuses to supply
correspondence regarding this decision
this is inexplicable senior officers
have refused to supply a full chronology
of decisions and there is no decision
record relating to the siting of the
pavilion in the firs so in deciding to
site the pavilion in the firs given the
flawed Stan's gait report and highway
recommendations now ignored by Council
let's wait and see if somebody gets
injured and by the way there have been
four accidents since the planning
decision mr. Curtis I'm going to have to
stop in deciding to cite mr. Curtis yes
please could you go to the question I
will indeed you know can you get a
question now otherwise it is not an
opportune
if you to give a personal statement
about issues which you may have
concerned could you please ask the
question thank you my question then
based on the evidence in deciding to
cite the pavilion in the firs given the
flawed stands gay report and highways
recommendations what consideration of
the relative negative impacts was made
by councilor organ and critically where
is that assessment and decision recorded
as there is no public record of the
decision to cite this gift in the first
Park thank you thank you mr. Curtis
would you like to respond please I thank
mr. Curtis for his supplementary
question and I have to say how much I
admire his tenacity on this issue we all
understand that not all decisions made
by any council will have full support
there may be one or two they are very
rare beasts likewise I think we have to
understand that not all residents are
necessarily opposed to this decision and
whilst the argument that is taking place
is about process I think the real nub of
the issue is the decision there is
always the process of judicial review or
the local government ombudsman if mr.
Curtis feels that there is a flaw in the
way that the council has actually
handled this issue and I do understand
that since the table was questioned
since the question was tabled there has
been a meeting held on the 22nd of
February and a further meeting has been
requested so those might be four
to carry on with this or as I said
either to undertake or look for a
judicial review or to seek the advice
and help from the local government
Ombudsman thank you
so where is the decision to cite it in
the foot since we have a number of
members of public who have come along
who are interested in this issue the
first written question and its answer
from the leader relates to the first I
wondered if we could bring that item
forward so that members of the public
can at least hear the answer to the
supplementary question let me consult
with my expert on my version
Cosimo's its counselor fradulent
question she's had a response from the
leader in writing do you have a
supplementary question on that because I
think we should I'm quite happy to take
that now so as you said it's holed up
within one mice
thank you for the answer my
supplementary question is if a meeting
is to be called with representatives
from the public I would like an
assurance that meeting would happen
before the birthday weekend would you
like this one
Thank You councillor family I would say
that if the meeting needs to be held it
will be held before Shakespeare's
birthday weekend thank you most I thank
you for that but I would have liked more
assurance that a leasing will be held
your question counselor frontally was
quite specific you asked if a meeting
would be held I answered it
thank you if we can therefore move if we
go back to the order for the agenda for
matters to return by this council the
first one is is point six update the
Constitution we have a report from the
monitoring officer and I now call upon
the leader of the council to present
this report
we are now moving on to point six items
on the agenda we have had eight we have
we have had a question from the member
of the public which has been for which
there has been a response I've asked to
change the order so that counts the
fragile ease question on the same topic
could be answered and that has been
answered by the leader as requested by
councilor fragile e it is now time to
move on if you wish to stay for the rest
of the meeting I'd be delighted for you
to do so
but this is a public meeting but guided
by the rules of council meetings and I
must request members of the public to
treat this meeting with the respect that
has always been treated with in the past
and hopefully will be in the future so
if you would like to stay thank you I
think we'll just adjourn the meeting
while these ladies and gentlemen if they
wish to leave leave
very early moment but if anybody does
want to get a glass of water or a
comfort break and we're just counselor
Pemberton has gone off we will just give
him the courtesy to come back and then
we will recommence
I'm sorry for that slight delay but I
think it's now time that we should re
connotes the meeting so if we go back to
0.6 update to Constitution
you've had a copy of the council's
morning officers report outlier members
Constitution I'll call the leader to
present this report Thank You chair one
thing I would say is that these updates
are intended to be effective from the
start of the new municipal year and one
of the reasons for actually bringing
forward these amendments is to recognize
the increased volume and complexity of
work on counselors at the moment we have
36 councilors than in reality in
operational terms that is probably
effectively about 30 I would just draw
members of tensions to point 110 where
it says the serve agent will be reviewed
after 12 months in operation and I think
we will change that to six months so
that in reality they change to planning
committees a and B will actually run for
six months after the start of the
municipal year and then the review I
would also say that in item 111
committee size the reality actually is
again for the regulatory committee it
has to be between 10 and 15 members so a
10 it is right on the minimum but given
the number of people we actually have as
councils that to me seems to be
appropriate I would also draw members
attention to redundant custom council
procedure rule 11 we will actually make
sure that councilors will have the
opportunity to us to raise any question
they have on committee reports Council
with that
would actually commend to counsel and
ask for any comments so a chair right do
we have any questions on counsel moss
Thank You chairman chairman I have no
problem with most of these proposals
however the exception and fact lines in
the papers is 1.21 the suggestion that
the Chairman can serve for more than one
term chairman I see no need for this at
all it doesn't happen at the county
council or most other councils why
should it happen here and there can't be
any shortage people willing to do the
job at least it never has been in the
past there are 36 councillors to choose
from I'm sure that we plenty of
volunteers of course Joan the part of
the problem may be that the
Conservatives only ever chew is a
conservative to be chairman but that's
not the case in most places and it
doesn't need to be the case here this is
an unnecessary change to the
Constitution I will be voting against
that change chairman Thank You
councillor Morse the reason for proposed
proposing this change is quite simple
there may well be occasions when a
Deputy Chair cannot take over from the
chair we also I think are in a situation
where come the new council there will be
a large number of new councils to me
this proposal seems extremely prudent
counselor forchick yeah in general I
think the change is a reasonably
sensible where I do have an issue with
its 1.20 that's questions to the leader
to require questions in writing and
advance notice of two days I think the
whole point of questions to leader is
actually asking the question on the day
and not in many respects it's actually
there are issues that come up during the
meeting itself there can be questions
have come up just within hours of a
meter
and I think it's right for councillors
to be able to ask a question without
advance notice to the leader who would
like to comment on that if it helps if
you turn to page 9 of the report this is
the appendix to the report yeah at the
top of the page it says thirteen point
five and the part at thirteen point six
is the bit that's been amended there all
that part in gray are additional words
so it would be that the question would
either have to clear days notice in
writing or if it's urgent and it has the
approval of the chairman of the Council
and the contents of the question is
given to the head of paid service by
10:00 o'clock on the day of the meeting
then it would be allowed to I don't know
whether that helps but that that's one
way of dealing with the issue you raise
comments and I think it's the principle
that's are rejecting to and advanced
notice I think usurped our rights of
opposition councillors to actually hold
the leader to account on the day itself
so notice I believe is is is actually
goes against my democratic principles to
actually ask the question without prior
notice so I do object to that point yes
how we take the reason for putting the
same on please the monitor officer
brought up the point about 10:00 a.m. on
the day it's so that you can actually
have a considered and thorough response
to a question rather than if I'm almost
about is sometimes stand up here and say
I'll have to get back to you on that and
I think there's a trade-off between what
you just said and whether you want a
thorough and complete answer to a
question
does anybody have any further issues
counsel sent Chairman I some sympathy
with counselor for checks point because
members for most members in here will
recognize that the previous leader had
questions without notice for seven full
years every single time there was a
council meeting and he certainly felt I
can speak from personal experience that
leader certainly felt very challenged
and times effectively but I never at any
time suggested somehow or other after a
few weeks in the job that I should
actually have life made easier by having
notice so to a degree I have some
sympathy with with counselor for Trek
but my main point of raising it as I
think you predicted counselor chair
monkish you wrote to me about it the
other day was this question of the size
of the regulatory committee now this is
mentioned in paragraph 1 e 11 okay it's
a fair point if there is a good reason
why it could be reduced to 10 and still
stay within the bounds of the law then
it is worth considering however as that
same leader that was in post for seven
years looked at this quite often during
his seven year tenure of that office I
can assure you that we did look at this
question why are there 11 members on the
regulatory committee
and we were told time and time and time
and time again that that was a legal
requirement yes we agreed we wouldn't
push it up to 15 because there was a
higher level because of the shortage of
numbers same logic is being applied to
the proposal before us today but in
reality when mr. Lancaster it was he's
not here to defend himself now
effectively was quite adamant to me that
that regulatory committee should
comprise 11 people I took that legal
advice seriously now I don't see in the
appendices any change to the
Constitution to regulate this so I
suspect what's happened is as you
slipped into your email to me the other
day that the Constitution has already
been changed to allow a minimum of 10
and mr. Grafton is nodding his head if
he hairs then that has happened without
authority because we did a review of the
Constitution a couple of years ago and
we had a member working party to do it
which I chaired and I don't remember the
size of the committee ever coming up
during that situation so we were told
then that effectively the the size of
the committee should be at least 11 and
that's the more we set he did it what it
was there was no mention of reducing it
to 10 because that was deemed to be
illegal and we worked at the lower end
of the bandwidth that we had available
to us therefore I think now the fact
that that the appendices don't show any
change to the Constitution for this
rather hides a problem that we have to
resolve here and now say why will we
given legal advice to that degree some
years ago if you're giving given
something different today thank you mr.
st. firstly please councilor st. if you
wish we call cancer st. delighted to
call you council sight
my email too dated 23rd of February
states the number in the Constitution is
10 as pointed out to me by an officer
who I won't name here but you know who
that officer is so unless it was changed
for that counsel's knowledge in other
words in error we have to assume that 10
is the approved number there has been no
amendment to the council council's
Constitution this respect while I have
been chairman and it might be a bit
harsh on counselor Atkinson to see if he
can recall a change the Constitution
taking place during his tenure but I'm
sure the monitoring officer who's on my
left will be able to confirm when or if
this was changed so just to help members
the reason that there are some
restrictions on the numbers for the
regulatory committees simply because it
also has to act as the council's
statutory licensing committee and within
the licensing legislation there are
requirements for the minimum and maximum
number that you can have for a licensing
committee and it's actually reproduced
in the terms of reference for the
regulatory committee and I'm just
reading from it now the statutory
licensing committee must consist of at
least 10 members but not more than 15
members okay to ask mr. Grafton
are you aware in your tenure whether
that Clause has been changed since you
took over as monitoring officer I'm I've
been here for five years and I know
there was a review of the Constitution
in 2014 as far as I can recall that rule
has been in operation for longer than
that so as I stated in my email to you
the number of the Constitution's 10 mr.
council st. if you wish to challenge
that perhaps you might like to write to
me with details of when you believe the
Constitution said a minimum
until we here so we will I would suggest
we let it rest but I'm delighted to
receive any correspondence you wish to
send to me as German and I'll Forge on
to counsel mr. Grafton
Kosar Atkinson Thank You chairman I can
confirm that there was no change in the
Constitution my term of office I tend to
believe the was actually in 2014 but
certainly it wasn't last year I'm 1 1 11
which is what I am referring to I am
very pleased to see that the joint
consultation and negotiation group is
reducing from 9 to 6 that to me gives
the right balance between the staff
representation and member representation
it is pleasing to see I know it was very
recent I asked for that to be done it
was about three years ago I think
now the other item on 111 is the
regulatory committee and Audit Committee
at one time they were one committee
whether or not that can be done now I
really pose the question because I think
it can and just I don't also know
chairman if we have got members on both
I'm not positive on that direction at
all but when you look at the time factor
for both committees and their meeting
and here if we're talking about demand
on human resources combination put out
the Audit Committee one meeting lasted
25 minutes the other 39 minutes one went
on for a long time one hour two minutes
and then with regulatory one hour one
hour 17 minutes those are well within
the three and a half if we're talking
about the demand on human resources I
believe here is a good opportunity to
satisfy that objective and amalgamate
the committee and to what it was
previously ordered and regulatory thank
you chairman
Thank You consequence of character
Vaudrey thank you Jeff so those brothers
Chris and I hadn't spotted so my
apologies before the points the point
you made about questions to the leader
if I find without nuclear czar to leave
you a question that it's impossible to
answer and he replies hard to get back
to you I think that's that's my bag and
I have to live with that if there's a
difficult question that you I would
think should know the answer to and you
don't and you expose your lack of
knowledge on something I mean that
suggested work for us in the truth to be
able to ask you should be on top of your
piece and if you're not you should be
exposed to such but the other issue here
is there may be something in that Lotus
punative given us where yours you know
something happens real-time you know we
see on our phones when we went out to
use it all that nonsense but when we use
our friends and we see there's a topic
come up that's relevant we should be
able to ask you something in real time
and a meeting I think it's a shame if
that prevents us from doing it maybe I
misunderstood but would be grateful if
in due course you could just clarify
that point but I would be ashamed I
think I tend to side but can't avoid
check on that point leader would you
like to comment on that understood I
understand and appreciate what comes
live Aubrey said in the light of what he
has said I am quite prepared to withdraw
the questions to the leaders should be
given in advance what I would say is
again if I cannot answer and I take your
point that maybe I should be on top of
the brief in those cases but if you do
something where I genuinely cannot
answer as long as members are happy that
I get back to them because what I'm not
going to do is stand here and ramble
about things that are pointless so with
with that proviso in mind I'm happy to
see that deleted from the paper
because the Perry moly Charles this will
be a Thank You chair just as chairman of
regulatory could I just point out it's
really in response to councilor
atkinson's query regulatory committees
we tend to have training on licensing
issues beforehand and therefore the
actual time of the regulatory committee
isn't just the time for regulatory
committee it also includes training on
licensing which is extremely valuable
for all the regulatory members thank you
know Calipari I know the leader to come
back of that Thank You councillor Perry
you make an excellent point
I think audit and standards and
regulatory are two different committees
in audit and standards are are
independent members so if one combine
them how would things work out my own
view is that there are genuinely two
different committees with two different
remix' because of Giles just in relation
to paragraph one point ten which is the
proposes to change constitutions of the
planning committees I entirely
understand and I support on balance the
40 practical reasons and inefficient
reasons to help the smooth running of
those committees given some of the
difficulties in having people there on
time or at all but I would just suggest
that when the agendas are compiled there
is a mind kept to trying to keep the
councillors who are sitting on each
committee for there to be some degree of
geographical I to the agenda because
it's actually very helpful to be on the
planning committee and become acquainted
with an area rather than necessarily the
whole district it can be quite that can
be quite difficult and there are
benefits to having you know good local
knowledge when you're making decisions
about the particular area that you're
considering so I think having the
flexibility will be useful but I think
also having a mind to the sort of
decisions that have been taken and
having a consistency
making in relation to those geographical
areas Thank You Council dolls the leader
wishes to come back a little Thank You
councillor Jones your points are well
made and noted and I think that is down
to the actual management of the agendas
of the committee what the point is
logged Council courage just on that last
point of canister jars I'd like to fully
support that idea it was always a
balance in my opinion to go to an a/b
system rather than keep the geographical
separateness but the benefits of moving
to an a/b outweighed the geography
question but if we can as cancer jar
suggests bear that in mind when putting
the committees together that would be a
very good idea
thank you sending else have any comments
oh can strike concern again German I
must pick up the point of our training
we don't have the same attitude for
planning training training is a separate
issue and I think if one just looks at
the ball that's what's the point of
getting members there as well as senior
officers for audit which last 25 minutes
I think a degree of imagination is
needed in order to get a distinction
here and have training as a separate
issue thank you contract concern any
further comments on this item but in
which case I suggest we move on we have
an amendment to paragraph 1 point 10
changing the number of months from 12 to
6 we therefore need an amendment
proposed and seconded from that item and
it's proposed by councilor Pemberton and
seconded by I think councilor organ all
can we are we are we agreed to accept
that amendment from 12 to 6 12 to 6
thank you
we then have a second amendment which is
to delete effectively paragraphs one
point one eight to one point one to zero
oh 1.1 1.2 0 FX sorry can we have a
proposal in a second no no it's one
point two questions at one point two
zero questions to the leader the cut the
leader as you've heard has proposed that
that is withdrawn and therefore I need
to propose on and come support for
nothing beats you cancel miles by a
millisecond are you super happy to
second it so please can we have are we
agreed the paragraph one point two zero
and we agreed thank you
we therefore go back to the original
motion subject to those amendments which
is change its constitution do we need a
vote on this or are we agreed to accept
these changes you'd like so counselor
moss is ask for vote on their members
the Constitution welcomes the moss is
interrupted to say you tried to nod it
through and I so I speak up I'm not
after a recorded vote I merely wanted to
vote and it appeared that you were
trying to do it through nodding it
through but can I point out to chairman
but I think you should abstain on this
issue the argument was put forward there
were many new counselors it may be
necessary that have a chairman serve a
second term I take it that refers to
yourself so I would suggest you have an
interest in this and ship perhaps at the
same Thank You counsel moss we did
discuss this with modern officer part of
the meeting
but if you would prefer me to step down
or abstain from this vote I'm very happy
if that will keep you happy at all I'm
gonna take all I want to achieve is
happy cancers swim demolishing officer
right so the suggestion is if we if we
have a vote on the split this we have we
have a vote on recommendation one as
amended and they will have a vote on pet
on recommendation 3 as on amended but I
will abstain on that matter I'm are you
happy for me to conduct the vote though
Thank You councillor all right all that
going back to the first the first
recommendation as amended all those in
favor of recommendation 1 all those
against abstentions one abstention
I think recommendation 1 is carried we
then move on to recommendation 3 and in
fact to make its absolute clear our last
counts O'Donnell as my vice chairman to
get me to take this one forward
so all those in favor of recommendation
three can you raise your hands and all
those against any abstentions thank you
right we can therefore move on to item
seven statements now you've all seen I'm
sure trolled through the the budget in
great detail I will however now ask the
leader to present his budget and then I
will ask subsequent to that represent
available Democrats to make their
recommendations after the leader thank
you
we're here to consider the budget and
agree the level of council tax for the
next financial year as you will all be
aware setting the budget is one of the
biggest responsibilities we have and
what you see before you today is a
result of at least 10 months worth
during the budget process we've
continued to seek the views of the
public local businesses staff partners
and of course councillors to ensure
everyone's opinion has been considered
before we finally make these decisions
we are committed to keep in any
increases in council tax to the minimum
possible and I can assure you that the
budget being proposed today represents
real value for money as councils will be
aware 2019-20 is the last year of the
four-year finance settlement from
central government for the first time
ever the council is receiving no revenue
support grant indeed in 2013-14 the
council received
3.9 million of this grant this was
reduced to a hundred and eleven thousand
last year and he's removed entirely for
twenty nineteen twenty that said the
budget you are being asked to approve
today
is balanced with a modest surplus a
modest contribution to our reserves we
are engaging with govern but through the
consultation on future allocation of
resources
however we are expecting that funding
the council receives through new homes
bonus will also reduce in future years
there are a number of key priorities
allowed within the budget that we are
putting forward today firstly and more
significantly we are allowing sufficient
resources to allow the council to take
control of the future of wells borne
airfield this facilities protected
within the core strategy that we
approved in July 2016 however the future
of well of aviation at wells borne is
under threat and that's why we committed
to take whatever action is necessary to
secure its ongoing operation a detailed
report on this issue will be considered
by cabinet at its next meeting on the
11th of March funding for the next three
years is also provided for Shakespeare's
England the destination management
organization the council helpful with
Warwick District Council and it's widely
acknowledged is one of those successful
in the country in these uncertain
political and economic times it is
extremely important we maintain our
funding to support this sector of a
local economy
the council is also undertaking a review
of the year bus community transport
schemed in the next year before making a
long-term funding commitment in this
area funding above 100,000 pounds has
been allowed in the medium term
financial plan to continue the service
until at least may 2020 we know how
important the scheme is for residents
however it is important that the scheme
is still relevant and provides value for
money for our residents for those
reasons we will be undertaking the
proposed review the impact of
homelessness has been a significant
issue to the council over the last few
years a number of measures have already
been taken by the council to really
reduce our reliance
Savan bed-and-breakfast accommodation
with the council leasing more units from
orbit and actually buying a number of
units to provide temporary accommodation
for individuals and families further
homelessness prevention measures are
proposed and funding within the proposed
budget as discussed in the state of the
district report in October the council
will be formulating a new corporate
strategy early in the municipal year
however in April council approved
investment of two and a half million in
key projects to support the current
strategy I'm pleased to report there's
been a significant progress in a number
of these initiatives including CCTV
consistently regarded by the public as
our most valuable service not only does
CCTV hope in crime reduction and
providing evidence to enable
prosecutions it is increasingly used to
help trace missing persons the project
which is underway will allow for the
replacement of the control room
equipment existing cameras and the
provision of further cameras across the
district this should be completed in the
next 12 months the strategic review was
reported to Council in October 2017 this
review included reviewing the way in
which the councillor words this has led
to the development of the ozone our
experimental working environment on the
second floor this will be used as a
blueprint for further investment of
three-quarters of a million in Elizabeth
house this will not only provide a
modern working environment for our staff
but also allows the council to let more
space to generate income to support the
council's overall budget within the
medium term financial plan further
savings of 400,000 pounds have been
assumed through transformation and
income generation opportunities in
arriving at the budget proposals for
next year we have again undertaken
significant and comprehensive
consultation
1,500 questionnaires were sent to local
residents seeking their opinion on how
they would like the council to use their
resources it is very pleasing to observe
the strong support for these results
from the decisions on council tax for
the decisions on council tax and the
funding proposed to help secure wells
one airfield it is also very reassuring
that ninety percent of respondents to
the questionnaire believe that the
council provides good or very good value
of money it's also very pleasing to
report that overall satisfaction with
all council services is seventy nine
point nine percent the highest since the
survey began in 20 2002 we're providing
briefings for members and the task and
finish group of our vien scrutiny
committees considered our alternative
budget proposals in finalizing this work
the cabinet received a report at the
meeting on 11th of February that the
proposals in front of you come to
consider today are clear achievable and
financially sound in addition to the
public and member consultation a
business forum was held recently at
Elizabeth house local businesses and
voluntary organizations took part in the
debate discussions concentrating on the
plans for stratford-upon-avon
including the concept of creating a
cultural quarter for the town then
constructing the budget for the next
year there's been a number of areas of
increased costs which have been
contained these costs related to areas
such as pay elections and pension cost
increases under course inflation a key
point I think people really do need to
understand is that other although our
reserves are currently 9.2 million over
the next four five years these are
forecast to reduce to 2.6 million in
reality our capability to use reserves
to fund or act our activities
in 20 23 24 finally in relation to
council tax for the next year given the
reductions in government support and the
budget pressures there is need for a
modest increase in council tax the
proposals within the papers before you
today allow for 1.5 percent increase in
council tax which means the bandy figure
would increase from 137 pounds and 7 P
239 pounds 12 P an increase of 2 pounds
and 5 pence this increase is
significantly less than the than the
amount and 5 pounds of the government is
expecting the council to increase
council tax this can be delivered
through the sound financial management
of the council resources this level of
council tax will be the lowest within
Warwickshire our will be amongst the
lowest 10% of district councils in the
country at a time when the level of
Taxation is at 49 year high it's
extremely pleasing to be in this
position
I commend this budget to Council Thank
You councillor Morris Thank You chairman
chairman I'll keep this fairly short at
least shorter than councillors jettison
anyway and keep concentrating on a
couple of things could I start by
reminding members of the promise made by
the Conservatives in their manifesto
before the last district council
elections over the next four years we
aim to keep council tax at the current
level now chairmen despite that promise
every year since you've put the council
tax up including this year and it's
worth noting but at the last council
meeting in December cats on Jefferson
admitted that arises plan for this year
could cause hardship and trim it's on
page 21 of your agenda you stated in
relation to the big increase in the
police pre-set I quote the leader
outlined his concerns that many
residents could struggle chairman how
much more must that apply
you take the count here district
increases indicate as well because this
year's cancel tax increase for a county
district and police and they're all
conservative control is 94 pounds for a
bandy player that's nearly 2 pounds a
week and an increase of 5.5 percent now
chairman CPI inflation in January with
1.8 percent so council taxpayers here
are having to pay an increase of more
than 3 times the current rate of
inflation now gentlemen I've heard
reserves mention and I've been told that
we must put the council tax up to keep
the reserves up because we'll need them
in the future indeed the forecast on
page 25 for the next five years shows
reserves steadily declining now mr.
Buckland that is a cautious man and he
should be in that position that's his
role but let's look at the past
performance on reserve to see whether it
provides any guidance on whether were
being overcautious and demanding money
from council taxpayers that we don't
actually need if we go back four years
to February 2015 a look at the forward
forecast we were told that by now
reserves will be down at 2.4 million but
now we're actually forecasting the out
Turner's 9.5 million six million pounds
better off than was forecast four years
ago and if we're short of money chairman
why did the cabinet agree in April to
spend an extra two and a half million
pounds of one-off projects in an attempt
to get the reserves down I suggest you
man that yet again this council will
turn out to be much better off and
actually than the forecast show I also
suggest chairman that residents are
entitled to ask why is this council
holding nearly one and a quarter years
of council tax income in reserves and I
might imagine that one or two we'll be
very surprised to discover that next
year the cabinet is planning to spend
1.1 million pounds that's one pound in
every seven taking in council tax on
legal and similar
costs relating to the compulsory
purchase of world's born airfield as
usual chairman that lawyer seem to be
benefiting it seems to me chairman that
the conservators the lost sight of the
fact that most residents will rather
have the money in their own bank
accounts rather than the District
Council's bank accounts chairman I'll be
putting forward some suggestions for
inclusion in the budget in the next
section
Chancellor Jefferson may agree or
disagree members may disagree or agree
but one thing they can't say chairman is
that we cannot afford them the figures
show that we can thank you Thank You
councillor Jefferson Thank You captain
the laws how are increasing the terms
for taxi my apologies Tony for you this
these are two statements there's no like
to reply shortly you to I think you have
made some specific comments to the
leader I'm I'm more than happy as
chairman let him to respond to some of
those concerns
and conservatory is indicating to speak
right okay just wait from
a suggestion for modern officers we
should move on to the next item which is
to the council procedural 62.5 is waived
which is a next item on the agenda and
then we need we need that proposal
seconded to continue and then we'll go
to comments from members after that you
happy with that so can I have a proposer
to a council procedural 16.5 be way to
allow one nominated member from each
group speak more than once on the budget
related items proposal for that council
say thank you can I have a second time
counselor Perry is everybody happy that
we should waive that regulation agreed
thank you very much right we can
therefore move on council Vaudrey you
wish to raise a point I know there'll be
an amendment later but I just thought
I'd just had a few comments on the
budget and just so no one's concern I
intend to vote in favor of it but what
what struck me when I read through this
budget was firstly in my opinion how
little ambition it had within it so here
we are only a couple of months before an
election maybe I'm a cynical old
politician but I would always expect
something quite exciting ahead of a head
of an election you know to imply to give
some lead indication of what might be in
a manifesto obviously I was kind of
liberals to quit last manifesto besides
remember I drafted it I've not been
asked this time have any contributions
the manifesto whatsoever I've obviously
done something wrong along the line
somewhere but I was surprised it's lack
of ambition and it's struck it struck me
that perhaps officers may well have
drafted this with very little amendment
from members to actually say this is
something dramatic Wigan to do it feels
if I may say not being disrespectful
like an accountant draft
this this budget and there's no vision
no nothing in there and if I'm a member
paying tax
I want something exciting to know that
it's going on and what a surprise for a
party that is a part of your business
there's virtually nothing in here that's
gonna help businesses out we have
businesses where you stand on the whole
European side everything that are Katie
struggling our major tax payer is
struggling heavily and there's nothing
in here either to help business directly
or to help the high streets which
featured a number of different towns
around the district where we see shops
closing down the number of charity shops
all the rest of it and there's nothing
in here that's going to directly affect
what we do with the high street which I
thought was very disappointing and
thirdly I just want to pick up on this
issue about wells born I am surprised
that we can provision for legal costs
but not actually for the cost of
acquisition I do wonder and I'd be
grateful perhaps if there has been legal
advice some common for the leader when
it comes to responding about what
guidance he's had about whether that is
legally correct you can only part
provision for something because if we
win the case and surely we're going to
spend that million pounds to win it
there then is some massive bill
subsequently but we've got to find the
money to do it and you know it strikes
me as a perfect thing that will be
judicially reviewed in due course if
we're not careful so I would be very
grateful for some clarification around
that to understand have we really made
sure we're legally watertight on where
we're going with this well one thing I
won't say anymore about well as one I've
got a question later on about it but
there are my key points I do intend to
vote for the budget I mean what I do
like the fact despite despite of the
Liberals comments is actually relatively
I think the increase is very de minimis
from Stratford districts councils point
of view I'm far more critical of what
the county and the police are doing in
terms of their massive increases in the
budget and I am pleased to say at least
it is a modest increase and I do
appreciate that thank you thank you I'm
now going to cuz Joss I gotta now move
on to the cabinet section which is
section
eight of the did you put your hand up
three you did chairman chairman for me
we've just seen been dealing with item
seven which is the opportunity for the
leader of the cancer and the leader of
the Opposition to present statements
with regard to the budget we should
really now be on item 8 which is
regarding the revenue and capital
budgets for this year so I'll leave it
in your hands as to they'll sing most
unfair you know one cancelling to speak
and not others I did raise the point at
the beginning that this was intended
ridgy just for two statements but you
overrule whichever which you have quite
in terms of who but it does seem unfair
to allow only one councillor then to
speak because walls I think what point
taken
we are not going to consider the cabin
of the budget as presented cabinet and
there will be a presentation from the
leader followed by you what I suggest is
that we then continue after that stage
further comments come through it's the
same budget it's the budget presented
the council or the one that's got a
cabinet hopefully it's the same piece of
paper so I take the point procedurally
you are absolutely correct and thank you
for advice so if we move forward point
eight we have the leaders next
presentation followed by yours and then
we will have questions from the floor
are you happy with that and if we could
just Park counts of Audrey's comments in
a temporary box and bring them out in
about five minutes in but terminus time
temporarily Cantrell water right and
we're there for
but we're now moving on to point eight
in accordance with local government
local authority Standing Orders England
amendment regulations 2014 there will be
a recorded vote taken on the revenue and
capital budgets 2019-20 I therefore now
invite Jefferson as leader of the
council to reduce item Thank You chair I
think I've already made most of the
points I wish to make in my statement
two things I would say actually which on
page 24 I think are significant one is
that if one looks at business rates
retention that is about to be reset that
will take quite a chunk of income of the
council and the new homes bonus which
actually is one of the reasons why we
have managed to build up good reserves
we have actually built an awful lot of
houses over the last three years which
is reflected in this and you will also
say that that declines very rapidly for
over the next four years in terms of
what we will be looking for in going
forward the reality actually is with the
new council we will be reexamining the
strategy but what I would say is that I
think this is a good budget
it is a prudent budget which given the
uncertainty in terms of economics and
politics is probably in my view
exceedingly wise thank you chair
Thank You counsel or chairman I've seen
when discussing the budget and I wish to
put an amendment but I do know that some
members wish to debate the points that
were made initially would it be better
if I proposed the amendment towards the
end of the debate so that members can
put their views forward on the budget as
it stands and then debate the amendment
but if I'm in your hands chairman
there's only one comment ask Alison Mott
Giles who's nodding away so I'm happy to
take comments from the floor at this
point and then we'll follow on with with
council Moss's amendments Kelsey jobs I
just wanted to say that it's important
not to take for granted how difficult it
can be for council to run a balanced
budget we only have to look at
Birmingham City Council who actually are
greatly indebted struggled to run some
basic public services for example a huge
library they've built is not open half
of the time because they aren't able to
staff and fund it the fact that we're
able to have a budget that's in surplus
a council tax which compared to the
average council tax across the country
is relatively low and we are able we get
good feedback on the public service we
run is a matter of great compliment to
this council the offices that work in it
and the councillors that do and it's
very easy to take for granted putting
together a good budget I actually would
say in response to council of Audrey's
comment that it that a budget that looks
like it's been put together by an
accountant is a great compliment that is
actually not to be derided and the other
thing I would say is that in response to
counts of orders comment that it lacks
ambition and what are we doing actually
I think it's highly commendable as a
party that we haven't thought to say
well we have an election in a couple of
months time right what can what can we
splash out on using taxpayers and money
in order to encourage votes that is
highly cynical I actually consider it to
be disgraceful activity whether it comes
from conservative labor or Lib Democrat
and actually the fact that we are saying
actually we find it in our job to put
together something which is proper money
management is something that
conservatives do well and I'm very proud
of that and for that reason I'll be very
happy to vote for this budget calipari
thank you chairman I just like to say on
behalf of my residents in Wales born a
huge thank you to the cabinet the leader
and the officers for actually doing
everything in their power to safeguard
the flying functions of Wales borne
airfield and over 200 jobs it means an
awful lot to put your money where your
mouth is and stop development that would
just infiltrate the village so on behalf
of my residents in my ward a very big
thank you and I commend the budget I'm
looking for council mr. Buckland Thank
You chairman I just want to make a point
that was raised by council Vaudrey in
relation to worlds where field and and
the budget report that you're
considering today does talk about the
legal costs necessary to affect the
procurement if necessary through the CPO
vote further reports have been presented
at the cabinet which deal with actually
how its successful through that Road the
council will fund the actual purchase
cost of the airfield and and that is in
public record so today we're just
dealing with the legal costs and not the
actual procurement costs thank you mr.
Buckland well if there are no other
comments on the leader statement we now
have some proposals to amend the budget
coming from
I assume coming from the leader of the
Liberal Democrats Council Moss you
assume correctly chairman thank you and
all members should have be circulated
with two pages of yellow paper and I
would point out that these proposals
have been through in scrutiny and being
judged to be fair and reasonable
financially achievable general I'll
cover them very briefly I won't take too
long there are eight points I hope
chairman in due course we can take a
vote on each of the
individually number one its clawback
something that we've regularly raised we
all know how long newer states can take
to build out is usually quite a few
years now where developers have
concessions on affordable housing
because of viability is used by the time
the estate is completely completed the
picture can have changed completely from
when the viability study was drawn up
chairman if circumstances do change and
the developer makes substantially more
profit than forecast then clawback
arrangements allow this council to share
in those profits so this proposal is for
the legal work in drawing up standard
clauses for clawback for insertion into
106 agreements secondly water fountains
the government has said that it will
abolish business rates on public toilets
so let's use the money this council will
save to cut the use of one-off use of
plastic water bottles by installing
water fountains chairman this proposal
is completely cost neutral thirdly the
land between the fisherman's car parking
stratford in the leisure center a
wonderful part of stratford that's
completely underutilized at the moment
so we're suggesting 20,000 pounds to
look at the options for the land we've
raised this issue before and the cabinet
did say that they would look at this
early this year while chairman here's
our money to do the research needed to
support their considerations next
electric charging points for cars in the
council's car parks I won't go on about
electric cars we're all familiar with
the arguments of how they're expanding
rapidly so it's fairly self-explanatory
but this would cover charging points in
ten car parks across the district germán
the Winter Street car park it's a
disgrace to our town this council gave
an option over the car park to a
developer five years ago in visiting the
demolition of the old car park in its
replacement with a new facility during
that time the state of the car park has
gone downhill
and the lift has been out of action for
years chairman this is a 10-story car
park with no lift where we grant
concessions for pensioners to use it in
the winter this proposals money for a
refurbishment at least to replace that
broken windows the peeling paint and the
potholes although not enough to replace
the lift at the same time Chairman I
think we should be looking at this whole
project and looking to see whether the
work on the Gateway scheme and not just
a car park will ever come to fruition
and if not what should we be doing about
it this corner of Stratford lets us all
down it's an important entrance of the
town so what sort of impression the
visitors get when they visit their gemin
the coach park is presumably the one
that visitors the Chinese pavilion and
the first garden will use can I suggest
that one can't so the jefferson takes
the Chinese guests probably at the
pavilion opening around the time he
gives wins a street car park in this
corner town of Miss they might otherwise
wonder what an earth they've got
themselves into they might even demand
their pavillion back sixth on the list
German is money for a traffic study for
slip road through the Stratford leisure
centre car park to help take some of the
traffic especially coaches off the
gyratory system this is not a new idea
but the traffic is getting worse and we
need to take some action over the
traffic chairman so this is a relatively
small sum to prepare a study of the
possible benefits seventh a small amount
to look at the options for landing
Studley now owned by the District
Council and finally a proposal around
empty shops the council Ivaldi says
something that people are becoming ever
more conscious of this is to promote
awareness of business rates relief for
charitable bodies landlords now have to
pay business rates on empty shops after
the first three months we're all getting
concerned about our town centres and
this is a great incentive to let shops
at no rent to charitable bodies which
can include museums and exhibitions as
well as charity shops
to help bring the shots back into use
chairman as I said it's tough I hope we
can treat each of these on their own
merits and take each one separately
thank you
Thank You councillor Pemberton Thank You
chairman just wanted to try and clarify
something councillor Morse has asked
that the that this meeting consider each
of these items separately councillor
Moss is an intelligent man and whilst I
disagree with the conclusions that he's
come to I've no doubt but his proposals
for an alternate budget which have gone
through over mutiny have gone through as
a package in their entirety and
therefore hanging together
as such it would seem therefore logical
that we should be considering the
package in its entirety and we should
therefore be taking the matters on block
because it would seem to me that to do
so individually would mean to have to I
couldn't see how we could rework the
budget if we have if this meeting were
minded to take you know one three five
and seven for example so to me I'm just
looking for some guidance and some
clarity and I would actually be moving a
motion that we do take them on block if
that's appropriate Thank You chairman
although they went through over history
they did not go through on block what
overview and scrutiny does is look to
make sure that they are clear and
financially affordable and reasonable it
does not consider each item line by line
now then mr. Buckland I'm quite sure
would be able to give guidance as to
whether we can finish the budget today
if we take oh be certain of these items
but chairman I can see absolutely no
reason why if members would want to
support several of them but not all of
them they should not be given that
opportunity it comes to organ did you
thank you thank you chairman yes I would
like to second cancer Pemberton's motion
to take it on block as it says thank you
to do it individually
I'm just going to take advice to the
monitor officer and the cancer sent
Kelso st. I was going to wait for you to
take your advice chairman I think the
mods are delighted to hear what you have
to say fast you might regret that I've
been looking through this piece of paper
that we've been given today and what
surprises me is with eight items in
there which are supposed to be budget
items only two of them actually
mentioned money now we all know that in
the papers that went to scrutiny
committee that the water fountains was
costed but there's no implement we
really asked today to make a decision on
things that simply are not costed and I
have considerably difficulty with that
whether we take them on block or whether
we take them individually now example
let's just pick that's one I picked the
options for the fisherman's car park
well we should have had some information
about some scoping exercise I would have
thought to make that worthy of support
the electric charging points has been
costed but we don't actually have any
technical officer verification of that
from an accountant or from the head of
technical services or what then we come
on to traffic study Stratford leisure
and visitor center well we all know that
the movement of vehicles around there
and there are several ways in and out
are they looking to reproduce the scheme
that was floating around a couple of
years ago perhaps four years ago whereby
you had a new entrance to the carpark
area off the Warwick Road I think we
ought to know this and we ought to be
able to appreciate it somewhat scoping
exercise series now the land that study
between the old library and the old
Medical Center sure what what that is
but however we again we haven't
details and charitable relief awareness
we starting talking about taking shops
on that that might have zero business
rates on them and offering them to
charities but I think those towns that
do have a mass of charity shops not too
particularly willing to encourage it so
I think we have to think very very
carefully before we do this in Stratford
Town Center if we indeed that is what
the proposal our council sent can I
respond to that because each item is
costed it is actually the shaded area on
the back page that the officers have
repaired
I admit cancer st. the shading is pretty
faint but it is there so each item has
been costed could I say two but each
item has been costed by officers these
are not my figures these are figures
that the officers have produced in
response to my request
thank you do we have any further
comments our counselor kept courage so
you did have your hand are fine oh thank
you very much just I suppose in response
to the Liberal Democrats I'll say it's a
question about steadily I'll keep my
mouth shut on everything except studly
whether I do have views on on many of
them the land it steadily refers to the
the Medical Center which was purchased
by this council with the intention of
developing in some way favorable to
Studley and I thank the cabinet and the
council very much for that action and
the subsequent work on looking into
developing this land was totally the
most recent part of that work is an
attempt to make a bid to the future high
streets fund not for ten thousand pounds
but in the region of millions perhaps
ten million we don't know we're looking
at that at the moment there's a group
hazel right from the other side myself
officers the parish council will shortly
be involved in other part as partners in
steadily to make a bid for a very
impressive change to the environment of
steadily so I am confident that this
council
it doesn't need to fiddle around with
with this kind of amount when we are we
are really attacking this at a much
grander scale already I appreciate the
thought but I think with our already and
I wouldn't mind a guarantee or a
statement from from our leader that even
if this bid is not successful and a bid
is a bid it may not be successful so
this cancer is dedicated to continuing
to help Studley in this particular
matter
council parameters
thank you just to give some clarity and
some some assurance to cancel a carriage
and and the the rest of members yes
there is work underway to look at a bid
for studly for the government's future a
high streets fund which may or may not
be successful but it is certainly
looking far more a far more strategic
and holistic approach to to a solution
there than this than this than this
envisages equally if that were
unsuccessful West Midlands combined
Authority which is also looking at
strategies around high streets and
market towns and I sits on the housing
and land delivery board and there will
be a second wave of funding through wmca
and that may or that may well be another
opportunity for studly and or another
one of our main rural centres for a
piece of work so just to give some
assurance that we are looking very very
closely at at all funding streams that
are available and that would that would
pretty much knock land it sturdily out
from if we do go on a line by line basis
from from the debate Thank You
councillor Barnes before you start
council bonds we are considering here
the amendments proposed by councillor
moss so if we can try and focus on that
at this point in the meeting please
councillor Barnes I was just going to
say really that study has been going on
a long time the new entrance into the
maybe not the neighborhood center but
the leisure center been going on a long
time the only thing that does look to be
to me modern is the charging for cars
I've got two pups now on one hotel that
I both got charges outside they're fully
used and if we need to move forward
that's something we need to do
young leader council Jefferson please
Thank You chair just looking through
these proposals options for fisherman's
car park these are under consideration
as part of a much wider study of
Stratford if we look at environmental
improvements to wins the street this
again is something that is under
consideration I don't think we need
separate proposals to deal with these
again the same is true with the traffic
study my colleague has already mentioned
the land at Studley so most of these
things are already one way or another on
the way
kalsekar go I will say one more thing to
that we've had a bit of a bad run on
consultants reports lately where a lot
of them have not been have lived up to
expectations and I am very reluctant yet
to put more money into consultants
reports without a decent business case
being put forward first of all as cancer
the Saint said so again I'm sorry I
can't accept this the rest of it has
been said thank you council fight
chicken
Thank You chair yeah I think these
proposals are very sensible and they're
there to actually do something quickly
to actually get things going and I take
the the comments that the councillor
Jefferson but have said about these
things are in hand we have to remember
that Windsor Street car park has been in
hand since I've been elected in 2015 and
absolutely nothing has actually happened
so I'll be supporting this proposal
toaster oven
thank you I shall repeat items that have
already been discussed other than to
just point out that there are actually
electric charging points and vehicles
already in the car parks in Stratford
biddeford Ulster and Salim and if you
want to have electric more charging
points in more car parks then of course
there needs to be an electricity supply
to get that but my main point is that
there are no proposals here to
compensate for this growth so there are
no proposals here as to what is going to
actually that the council will stop
doing in order to finance this and
produce a balanced budget because these
proposals will actually create a deficit
budget and that is something that I
could not support thank you right I'm
looking around I can't see anybody who
wishes any further comment so councillor
Atkinson councillor mortars explanation
about the shaded areas you certainly do
need strong binoculars to see it but I I
just you know on the very back page and
I'm sorry I don't understand these
things actually provision of electric
charging points on the front we say
50,000 the break up adds up to 18,000
the same for this environmental
improvements to Windsor Street mm in the
next financial year you may get three of
the broken windows replaced there and I
presume the other 55 are coming in the
next year's installation of a water
fountain no costs so what the devil does
cancer and moss mean the shaded areas
cover all of the expenditure which they
are seeking to provide in the budget
went from my interpretation of the
information here a little bit
topsy-turvy mr. mr. Buckland will
respond on that
Thank You chairman the budget contains a
mixture of both revenue and capital
items that the ones where we have
identified the capital spend what's
included within the schedule have you
have in front of you is then the revenue
implications of spending that capital
money so that's my in relation to say
the the Windsor Street improvements
we've allowed for effectively less
interest on the investment that we would
otherwise invest in relation to the
water fountains what you haven't gone
which needs the benefit at the paper
that went to the RSC which identified
that the source of financing for the
water fountains will be the new toilet
relief that was announced as part of the
budget in November where local
authorities will receive business rate
relief on the toilets which are commonly
provided so I apologize I should provide
the further information on that point
thank you Evan I must say it's a bit
flushed with confusion I think after
that comment everything sort of silence
surely if there are no other if there
are no other comments ladies gentlemen
we do have a number of amendments
proposed to the budget and I've heard
councillor Pemberton proposal about this
and I have quietly talked through this
with the monitoring officer and under
paragraph 16.6 the Constitution it is
clear that each amendment should be
discarded considered separately now
there is an argument to say that this is
one a member to the whole budget there
is an argument to say there are eight
amendments the same budget through the
budget here I think in the interest of
openness it be appropriate to consider
the eight in Lima 16.6 as amendments
rather than an amendment I apologize to
officers who again have to take seven
more recorded votes on this and let us
just try drew this if council moss will
help me as expeditiously as possible
and so we will seconder this one what I
do need though is for councillor Morse's
request for this to be to be seconded
so could you have us do have a seconder
for that yes chairman I'm on the basis
of the advice I'm happy to withdraw the
proposal to taken on block and we do it
line by line if that's the advice I'm
happy to take that Thank You council in
which case may I suggest that the first
challenger on you have a paid service is
how to whiz through eight at least eight
recorded votes as quickly as possible
and therefore if we move it as happy now
in in numerical order starting with
clawback arrangements that we have a
real conscious of we're if there's a
general feeling that members are going
to vote particular way on all of them
could we take the vote on the first and
then just take different votes
exceptions on the remaining seven would
that help to speed things up we are
required to have a recorded vote on
amendments and therefore I think whilst
I appreciate your suggestion unless we
do it initial prepared to accept this is
one amendment enough we'll have one vote
that we should take we should actually
run through each individual one in
accordance with the Constitution I think
it is it is simpler not trying I've been
helped I think perhaps we could take a
vote on whether members are minded to
consider these individually if the
overwhelming opinion as I suspect it
might be is to reject only I will then
withdraw the request for a recorded vote
from each one subject to approval for
modern officer give me one minute right
can we what I suggest is I'm going to
ask all those in favor of having these
amendments treated individually
in other words eight recorded votes so
all those in favor of individual votes
shut up that's for all those against
that proposal we therefore have Thank
You councillor moss for the drawing that
suggestion
we now have one amendment to the budget
which is the Liberal Democrat amendment
as described by council moss earlier on
with this will be a recorded vote
and therefore the wording will be to
whether this council wishes to accept
the Liberal Democrat amendment to the
budget so I'm now going to ask how to
pay service to start the recording
please hello so you'll be so I didn't
realize I was supposed to stand earlier
so I'm now standing and okay so I'm
going to go through this and I can you
plea clearly state for abstain or
against so chairman Kettle against vice
chairman o'donnell against council
Atkinson Council Adams Council ibaka yes
counselor bonds
counselor brain vomitus apologies
counselor Cargill okay
cancel the Crump counselor fielding
cancel the phytic acid freshly counselor
Giles against cats legacies apologies
counselor grey council Harris counselor
howls counselor Jefferson against
counselor Kendall is apologies counselor
carriage counselor Lawton counselor
Mills against counselor Moss counselor
organ against counselor parry counselor
Pemberton against counselor Richards
counselor Rich's absent sorry counselor
Ralph Council of st. yes counselor
farewell Council of Audrey counselor
Williams and cancel the writers
apologies
those gentlemen I'm advised that the
result of the recorded vote is that the
Liberal Democrat amendment budget is
rejected we therefore move to the vote
on the the actual budget itself which
again will be a recorded vote and
therefore I'm going to ask the head of
paid service to run through now this
let's get this correct this is to vote
for the leaders budget as described
earlier on so all those so will now run
to the recorded vote
okay chairman council kettle for
councillor O'Donnell for council
Aaronson councillor Adams Council ibaka
councillor Barnes councilor brain vomit
apologies counts the cargo councillor
Crump councillor fielding councillor for
tech against councillor fragile e
councillor Giles ghitis apologies
councillor grey council Harris
councillor house counsel Jackson
Kendall apologies councillor carriage
councillor Lawton councillor meals for
Council Morse council organ councillor
Perry councillor Pemberton or counselor
Richards Rich's apologies councillor off
that's the saint for counselor farewell
capsule of Audrey Cutler Williams and
right apologies I'm advised that the
budget as proposed by leader is carried
we therefore move on to point eight
which is Prudential educators I invite
council Jefferson new to the council
fruit juices item
all right 0.9 Northpoint aid
Kosar deafness is referring list
accounts for organ cancer organ would
you like to present this item Thank You
chairman these are to ensure that the
capital investment plans of local
authorities are affordable prudent and
sustainable the calculation of the
Prudential indicators is mandatory and
the recommendation is that the
Prudential indicators for nineteen
twenty contained within the report are
approved thank you
I tried to read a lot again does anybody
have any issues that we should raise
questions to the portfolio holder on the
production indicators it's a no debate
are we agreed thank you can we remove
therefore on to number 10 treasury
management strategy and I will call
again on counsel organ to introduce this
item thank you the annual Treasury
strategy is drawn up in line with both
of the GCL G guidance and the cipa code
of practice and includes the council's
capital plans minimum revenue position
policy how investments and borrowings
are organized and how investments are
managed the proposed strategy details
which investments the council may use in
addition it limits the council's overall
borrowing to 20 million including the
council short-term borrowing of 10
million and permits variable interest
rate on borrowing the council currently
has no plans to borrow in order to fund
its medium term financial plan however
there is a requirement to set limits
regardless of this in addition this year
is the first year of the new capital and
investment strategy that provides both
the framework and a mechanism whereby
capital expenditure and investment
decisions are aligned over the
medium-term period and ensures that all
new funding is targeted at meeting the
priorities of the council whilst
ensuring that the council is aware of
the risks associated with such
activities the recommendations are
printed on page 30 and there are four
there thank you thank you sin ebuddy
wish to raise any questions of the
portfolio holder in which case are we
agreed to take our report forward
thank you we therefore move on to point
11 council tax 20 1920 in accordance
with local authorities Standing Orders
England amendment regulation of 2014 a
recorded vote will be taken on the
council tax in 2019 20 are therefore now
invite to Council of Jefferson as lead
with the council to introduce this item
Thank You chair this should be fairly
straightforward having approved the
budget we now have to formally approve
the council tax resolution as contained
in Appendix 1 which contains from not
only the parents for the dish
what extra County Council and for what
extra police and crime Commissioner so
the recommendation is to approve the
formal council tax resolution at
Appendix 1 Thank You leader do this
everybody which to raise any items
honest or any comments for the leader
if not we as I've already noticed we
will be having a recorded vote on this
I'm just looking at councillor moss do
you wish to resume once no thank you
therefore we'll move straight to the
vote recorded vote I'll ask the head of
paid service to conduct the recording
later ok chairman kettle for for
councillor Atkinson councillor Adams
councillor Barca councillor Barnes
counselor brain from which apologies
counselor car girl or counselor Crump
counselor fielding cuts Lefroy tech
abstain counselor fragile a counselor
Giles full gist apologies counselor grey
Council Harris counselor House Counsel
Jefferson for Kendall apologies
counselor carriage counselor Lawton or
counselor meals for counsel Awards
Council organ for capsule aperi
counselor Pemberton for counselor
Richards which is apologies counselor
role counselor st. for counselor
farewell counsel of Audrey counselor
Williams he's temporarily left the
chamber probably gone to a chamber
24 for I'm advised that the motion is
carried
we therefore move on to points 12 and I
by Councillor Pemberton produces item
Thank You chairman
this item is one in a series of
development requirements supplementary
planning documents that the authority is
is bringing on and this latest one it
relates to district heating schemes the
report and the recommendations were
considered by cabin or two resolved to
recommend that part Q the district
heating networks be adopted as part of
the development requirements
supplementary planning documents and
that they be adopted by this Authority
and seek members of this council support
for that recommendation which is
outlined on page 42 Thank You senator
wish to raise any items on this in which
case can we move straight forward to are
we agreed thank you
number 13 employee code of conduct I
might come to Jeff Sanders chairman the
point in the point this committee
Thank You chair this is the employee
code of conduct which was considered my
employment apartments committee the
option the recommendation to council is
to note the new employment Col employee
code of conduct as adopted and to update
the Constitution accordingly
right who has any points there was
raised on this item if there are none
I suggest are we agreed over the page
and this relates to pay policy statement
again I can't invite counsel Jefferson
and now we have a place of service has
actually declared an interest on this
item does the counsel wish her to leave
the room at having declared that
interest or his cuts will have people to
remain in the chamber thank you thank
you this is the pay policy statement
2019-20
I would just draw council's attention to
the last paragraph on page 45 the
committee accepted that the proposed pay
policy statement more than met the legal
requirements of the Localism Act and so
to achieve best practice rather than
just legal compliance and with that can
I just say the pay policy statement for
2019 $23
any questions comments if not are we
agreed sure we therefore move on to item
15 committee reports for information
only we have a Med of the Constitution
I've referred to earlier but this item
will not change until the new council
year so I'm going to invite well I was
going to invite counsel st. but he
appears to advocated his chair so I
think we'll have to pass on that one
I apply man appointments committee
counsel Jefferson I'd like to report the
minutes of the employment and
appointments committee held on the 7th
affair to Council
Thank You council Jefferson over in
domestic committee it comes to Parker
can I commend the over the under
scrutiny committee
minutes of the fifth of December last
year 9th of January and the 6th of
February this year Thank You counselor
Perry regulation committee Thank You
chair I'd like to commend the minutes of
the regulatory committee on the 1st of
February which are is online thank you
thank you cabinet counsel Jefferson
Thank You chair the minutes of cabinet's
held on the 10th of December minutes 424
to 427 considered it council on 17th of
December and also the minutes of the
14th of John and the 11th of 5th Thank
You Council Jefferson are there any
questions from any members of the
council on on on those items so mr.
reasoner if not we'll move on to outside
bodies and I now call upon the leader
the council to present report on outside
bodies this is just a report on the
outside bodies which members of the
council actually attend it is a list
that is updated every year I'd really
don't think I need to say any more than
that does anybody have any questions on
outside bodies or any of those who turn
them in which case will comment thank
you and to thank all members who have
responded to this the depth of replies
from members various enormous Lea from
some people who have just given a
one-line description of what the outside
body does to people like yourself
chairman you've provided a very
comprehensive breakdown of what was
discussed
I wonder up for the future if some
guidelines could be set to members as to
what their report back should comprise I
think members are interested in how
these bodies affect this council or our
district and those are the highlights I
think people need just some guidance for
the future chairman not to be too
so I did this meeting that perhaps in
some other way thank you thank you guys
for more so I take the comments thank
you
what I was just is the monitoring
officer the executive directors and the
leader myself discuss as to a way we
might go forward so that we we meet some
of your concerns we will deal with that
outside this meeting we therefore move
on two counts of questions sorry there
any questions on that comment nope any
further questions of it in which case
move on 17 we have nine questions and
the onsens being circulated on separate
sheet counts the prejudice question has
already been addressed by the leader I
assume that you don't wish to come back
on that one can Spradley thank you for
actually banette forward
thank you consequently in which case
we'll move on to item 2 which is comes
the mortis question do you have a
supplementary question counselor about
the Gateway project I see here the first
line of the responses progress on both
these proposals since October has been
limited chairman can we speed this up
please council Jefferson as I'm sure you
appreciate counsel Morse actually
driving this forward is not entirely
under our control we are doing what we
can to expedite matters but it is not
straightforward or simply because the
organ is very the holder would you like
to add any comment on that
I think cancer Jefferson has responded I
don't think that's very much that I can
add other than there is a proposal going
forward as part of the site allocations
plan which is included in the reply on
the paper thank you
thank you remove on accounts question
three canceled right who's not actually
here so I'm not one of her colleagues
might be able to are supplementary
through is one right okay thank you
if we move on to question four which is
counselor most you have a supplementary
question Thank You counsel moss counts
of fragile a question number five do you
have a supplemental question just
briefly thank you for the answer but I
understand from the second table that 31
people from November last year
are still waiting for information to
facilitate their moods if I've got my
understanding correct
I was actually first alerted to this
through a first time buyer last year who
just almost lost their purchase because
of delays I understand the reasons for
it but I would just actually ask for
expediency in this matter
thank you just to give cash the fragile
e and every other member in this chamber
some assurance the the service engages
through specialized search companies and
through the solicitors and there is
active work underway to ensure that
there is a mechanism by which those
organizations can flag to the team if
there is a urgency about a particular
search that may put the transaction at
risk and part and parcel of the planning
around reducing the backlog is to allow
for resource to attack the backlog what
comes in on with in-service standard and
also to have capacity to deal with the
sort of ones that come up on the rails
as being particularly urgent for
whatever reason I can also confirm that
touchwood to date we're not aware of any
transaction that has fallen by the
wayside as a result of the LAN charges
services operation or its or its ability
to turn round you can see that there's
been significant progress I get weekly
updates on reporting
there are monthly updates into OSC our
offices are all on top of this I'm
really just reporting the good work that
they're doing so I can't give you
assurance that yes this is moving in
absolutely the right direction and I
would anticipate that certainly by the
time you get to the next OSC update
those numbers in descent in November
will have dropped from markedly Thank
You counselor off question six
no sorry counselor off question seven
do you have a supplementary question I'm
pleased to say that we are going to have
metal teaspoons there six propounded
permanent so you get thirty four five
I'm happy to wait for that because I
think the sooner we get rid of these
plastic stirs the better thank you
Thank You councillor Roth
it comes to Vaudrey did you have a
supplementary you really brought this up
earlier on I do
I've worded this question carefully I
want to avoid the response being oh it's
commercially sensitive so there's
nothing to do with the actual situation
with any counterparties it's to do with
the council so if I could ask beyond
what level of funding would the council
actually be a risk and just as an
addition to that I would be grateful if
any office for advice that supports the
statement the counter is not considered
to be a risk of default could be made
public it sounds from what mr. Baca said
earlier on that maybe there is something
the public domain already I have not
seen but beyond what level of funding
would we be a risk council organ council
I apologize I don't know if we should
come back on count some walls no that's
quite all right
the there is already a facility for
borrowing for ten million pounds if
required
so anything up to ten million pounds is
covered by that facility but
nevertheless without having to dip into
that facility the capital council does
have reserves which have been referred
to earlier
that can also be used that of course
removes them from reserve someone would
have to look at replacing those reserves
but I think one of the arguments in
favor of retaining wells born as a
working airfield is the argument that it
is industrial use which brings
additional prosperity in the distant
into the district and ownership of that
could would actually improve the
financial flow of the council's coffers
thank you
did you have any would you wish to make
any comment to go back to Council or
supplementary question sorry
Thank You chairman I completely moved on
so I've got to move back again I didn't
actually identify a question from the
follow-up words from cancer Ralph and
yes I think we have a duty though as a
council to actually use the existing
stock first rather than to throw it all
away which would really be I think quite
negligent thank you thank you write
cursive audrey your your second question
you have a supplementary just effect
just remind council which is not some
like that about making officer device
available and I'm presuming 10+2 in
reserves as 12 million so I'm taking it
at the no more than 12 million whatever
we spent on buying on wells borne
airfield my second question is you know
a few years ago it was clearly I got a
lot of stick for criticizing the police
I think it's a shame that the police
today have to increase their budget by
this much I still think there's
economies of scales and I'm still amazed
that we've split up from West Mercia
without anyone seem to know that I was
coming down the line but my question
today is given last year's budget I'm
advised men we've got one extra
policeman on the beach and given the
answer the leaders given here
could he let me know approximately and I
know me a ball python but approximately
over the next 12 months how many
additional policemen net additional
policemen are we in this district
genesee pounding the streets in the
towns and the villages so we can
actually point to something and say
that's what we're paying for and we're
starting to get some value for money
from this police force council Jefferson
I can't answer that question
specifically Council of the Audry what I
can say is that the police and crime
Commissioner has said that they will
recruit a hundred extra staff the police
operate a five shift system and there
are five districts I think that gives
some indication of the level of resource
one might say per shift per district
however it's not quite as simple as that
because they do roster them to take
account of where the most activity takes
place so the shift where you've got the
most crime is the shift they've put the
most people on one thing I would say as
well and it is something that does cause
me a bit of concern in terms of
recruitment there is not only the
recruitment process to go through but
there is the training process to go
through as well I would say that in
reality it will not be next year when
these police are effective it will
probably be the year after and from what
what I understand from what happened
this year when the preset went up 12
pounds and there was meant to be
recruitment to police officers
what really seemed to catch the police
out was the fact that they had not fully
understood the amount of turnover in the
police and although they were recruiting
the turnover and the lags in the system
effectively meant they got one more
I think this really is a matter of
concern and I think it is something that
I would hope the police and crime panel
really does hold both the police and
crime Commissioner and
the Chief Constable to account for next
year the other thing I would say as well
is that the nature of crime is changing
and in particular I would draw attention
to the rise of county lines and I can
say this because it was quoted in The
Economist over the weekend there are
four thousand five hundred and forty two
gangs quite a precise number thirty
seven thousand three hundred and
seventeen criminals and organized crime
costs thirty-seven cost the UK 37
billion in 2015-16 the reality now is
the whole crime picture is getting more
complex and I think it will be how one
actually really holds the police to
account across all dimensions of crime I
have asked that there is a report to
police and crime panel on county lines
and he will actually see from the
response we put you down as a priority
my view actually is that this is one of
the greatest threats that we actually
face in this district because it feeds
the drugs habit and through that it
feeds an awful lot of crime and violence
I have to say I am really concerned
about the county lines operations in our
district thank you for that
comprehensive response on something
that's actually under your review time
cuts of order accepts
Jefferson's position right if we move on
then we have questions for leader sorry
Luke he died so you got that first
counselor Rolf would you like to start
the batting I've recently been alerted
to the fact that there could be a change
very soon to our grant system and vassal
will not automatically receive what they
have received in the past master employ
a community engagement officer to
organize all the social prescribing
events for the older vulnerable members
of our district and it could mean that
they'll be no longer be lunch clubs tea
and chat exercise classes in classes etc
this role could be lost if funding stops
and several other clubs does the leader
share my concerns Thank You counsel
Ralph
grants to voluntary organizations are
kept under review I'm not aware of the
precise details of what will be
happening next year but I do know that
the grants are kept under review and
they are targeted at where people think
the greatest needs are so one cart just
consider Vasa in isolation I will look
at the position and get back to you with
what I am told how's the forecheck how's
it going next thank you Thank You chair
I'll go with both questions the same
time first question is related to a
question I asked at the last council
meeting and I'll repeat it
what actions would this council take to
help families next year following a
recent changes to the Universal Credit
System and how could Stratford District
Council reduce the growing reliance on
food banks now the answer I received
then was that the leader would
investigate what actions this council
could take
on these important issues since then
I've had nothing so I don't know how low
down or how high up it is on the leaders
list of priorities but I would have
hoped of some feedback on them the
second question is on the nighttime
economy in the district primarily in
Stratford as it is the biggest town in
the district and it's we know it's an
essential part of the local economy with
the theatre restaurants and sort of bars
being a vital part of our employment and
generation of wealth for the town and
its businesses would you need to agree
that young people in the town don't
appear to benefit from this nightlife
it generally finishes relatively early
and the missing part of our nighttime
economy are some like late night venues
would lead to agree that they should we
should be encouraging this through in
more innovative ways that we can promote
businesses wanting later licences thank
you
Thank You councillor phytic on universal
credit and what the council can do I
apologize for not getting back to you
again this is something I will look at
because Universal Credit obviously is
not something the District Council does
there are impacts from it that really do
affect our residents and affect them
quite considerably there may be
something we can do with through banks
what we need to explore that further
coming to the nighttime economy I would
agree with you but what the council can
actually do is quite limited because in
reality these tend to be private sector
commercial operations we do have a
project underway to look at a vision for
stratford-upon-avon Town and as part of
that I am sure we will be looking at the
nighttime economy one of the things I
would say
that it may well be I'm not putting time
for people to look at creative ways of
providing more nights unbecomingly for
young people because if one actually
looks at the high street it is pretty
obvious that rents are starting to drop
that may well mean that operations that
were not economic a couple of years ago
or become much more economic in the
future I have read that there are
retailers that are now getting 25%
reductions on rents so that may well
create an awful lot of possibilities for
entrepreneurs whatever we could do to
support that we would but I would have
to say I think it is actually limited
Thank You councillor Vaudrey two
questions I'm happy to ask them both at
the same time though they're very
unrelated first one is are there and
given this new culture of nice
conversations or those of other bodies
we deal with are there any live
conversations going on now about the
practicalities of unitary authority
second question is given the importance
of the Gateway project that's been
raised I remember my day when I was back
in the cabinet I used to get a bit of
grief excited to meet with mr. Warrick
and actually try and push that forward
and counts an organ used to object me
interfering in her patch could I ask how
often his council organ met with mr.
Warrick over the last 12 months
picking up the industry authority one
first there's there are no live
discussions going on at the moment but
it is something that we have if you like
on our agenda for the future in terms of
the gateway of projects I can't comment
on linear organ but had I've had one
meeting with Peter Warrick in the last
nine months in an attempt to move the
Gateway project forward and I have to
say it was not successful council
council morsel Milt that was close mr.
chairman and have to say I do apologize
councillor Mills and cancel my look
similar but they are thank you thanks
Rick leader thank you I'm concerned that
the orbit Housing Association seems to
have a policy of setting off their
property in kind and the surrounding
areas in particular they have sold
bundling kinds in which would have been
ideal for elderly residents wanting to
downsize orbit are now advertising
two-bedroom flats for sale in Kyneton
and there's also a house up for auction
I have to say I looked at the online of
the house in question I must say it
really doesn't look too bad to me I have
a family who are desperate to move out
of their fat to a house and this house
would be perfect for them I'll get on to
the to the question I have our asked
orbit whether it's their policy to
intentionally poorly maintained their
properties to not make them viable
financially viable financially I have in
fact Alice's question three times of the
orbit directors but they have chosen not
to reply as in the case that bungalows
they have stated that cost to bring them
up to exceptional standards of standards
is too great I understand that the
elderly residents who are finding it
difficult to manage the stairs in their
houses are offered an alternative
accommodation in Welles born
this is unacceptable as it actively
breaks up communities in one instance an
elderly resident who has lived in kinds
of over 40 years was inspected to move
to wells ball understandably she's
struggling with her stairs and she does
not wish to move away from her friends
therefore a bungalow would have been
ideal for her situation with over 4,000
people in our housing register it is it
right that social housing has been sold
off into the private sector which is
just compounding the situation leader
can I ask that you raise this matter
with orbit Housing Association
Association as a matter of urgency
before we see yet another rise in our
housing register I know the Chairman has
also been in contact with the orbit on
the same issues and mr. chairman just
one other thing we just really not
related to this and I was looking online
before the meeting officially it is the
hottest day of the year
23 degrees in Wales I thought you'd like
to know thank you for the news from work
Wales councillor Mills this is not the
first time my third comments about orbit
housing in the strategy in the villages
it is certainly something I will be more
than happy to take up with the chief
executive of orbit and I do know how
much concern this actually causes so I
will do that as soon as I possibly can
I'm just going to feel quite right
councillors I did meet mr. Paul Richards
of orbit in relation similar concerns
I'm very happy to circulate a file note
that he'd seen of that meeting to
members if they so wish perhaps they
could email me cancel fielding saying
I've managed to save one bungalow in
tighter
God knows how and I'm also getting them
to repair two buildings one outside my
ward again getting to the right person
who is taking these matters seriously is
important although the person I'm
talking to is not one of the directors
she seems to be very on the ball and her
name was given to actually buy a NIC
card if I got the right one some time
ago so there is a chance of getting to
the right person does seem to work
Thank You councillor fielding it will be
very useful to actually have the
information and have knowledge of your
experience because that may well be
useful in discussing it with orbit
directors Council
Caerphilly I was actually thinking about
asking her to come to a meeting at the
district council office say if I can
arrange it with you and councillor Mills
they would be very useful Thank You
council feeling any other questions for
the leader if not we will move on to
item 19 a notice of motion update for
information only members have had this
rule have been able to witness the
cabinet debate and the resolve that the
notice of motion was rejected or
rejected we therefore move on to item 20
a new notice of motion
I call on councillor Richards and not to
propose and second the following notices
of motion
thank you chairman and the motion says
all it needs to say really so I'm quite
here simply to formally propose it thank
you thank you chairman yes and I'm quite
happy to second this excellent proposal
right accordance with our normal
procedure rules the motion has been
proposed by a council Richardson
seconded by Councillor Morton and
therefore will refer to cabinet for
cabin for consider and report back to
this next council meeting which moving
on to 21 as there is no further factual
business that meeting will be on the
15th of April 2019 and I look forward to
seeing you all there and therefore now
declare this meeting closed at 4:24